go to college then you can do what you
are despite reports that Olivia Jade and
sister Bella Jia newly were kicked out
of their sorority at USC et can confirm
that is false the Kappa Kappa Gamma
Delta Tau chapter at SC was quick to put
rumors to rest after reports surfaced
that they were trying to distance
themselves from the girls releasing a
statement to ET on Wednesday confirming
Bella is still an active member of the
Delta Tau chapter but when it comes to
Bella's 19 year old sister the sorority
says Olivia Jade did not complete the
membership process since March Olivia
and Bella have laid low after their
parents Laurie Lachlan and Massimo gia
newly were indicted for their alleged
involvement in the nationwide college
admissions scandal I want to be
supportive of everything they want to do
but I do want them to have somewhat of a
normal you know finish out of high
school college experience maybe because
I didn't have that I really want that
for them back in May a source told et
Olivia is having a hard time dealing
with this and for the most part she's
cut herself off from her mother and is
going out and partying a lot but last
month the source told ET that Lori's
relationship with Olivia has improved
everybody makes mistakes no parent is
perfect clearly as the news comes just
days after Olivia and Bella
simultaneously returned to social media
to wish Lori a happy birthday we're just
a nice normal family you know like we
don't weird we don't have anything
outrageous really happening